I don't really feel anything yet
then take another one Buffett ePrint I
really feel like reading oh and any beds
Oh James reminds me of my dad
what about manchild - I'm I really like
lowest common denominator stoner
comedies no no you owe me money
hi could I get I got two for space way
Oh DreamWorks tickets uh yeah hey hey
fin you do the tickets oh you have the
ticket can't seem to find them do I have
the tickets yeah okay I mean I just had
them you're my fault these people saw me
you saw me I lost my phone okay um
retrace your steps
oh I got him all right here enjoy your
show you too
I can't say smile I'm really starting to
feel it now I hope I run into anyone I
know that Britney Britney Ashley oh my
gosh we keep running into each other
oh hey man how are ya hi yeah I was just
taking her Tino's little brother out to
see a movie see the space reindeer oh my
god Weezy's
it's manchild - so we definitely can't
sit next to you I have to find my phone
and use the bathroom okay I gotta go
both busted allergies and contact lens
problems we were crying a lot - so we
were crying a lot today - it's the
strongest little guy I know I think I
took too much the second one is just now
kicking it am I gonna be this high
forever Kevin James Kevin James you
overdose indeed oh hey cool hat by the
way we actually picked up a couple of
these - these will be our movie hats
hung bud it's the strongest little kid I
know
gotta find Chris saw no movie can be
better than that preview
sorry you hanging guys really creepy hi
friend Chris seems fine
Martina would have loved this CGI that's
Hitchcock's vertigo Xue I don't know if
he's watching the film I think he just
likes being in a dark room